This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the very important psychology of our 20s. I've got a question. Have you ever had that feeling of meeting someone amazing, feeling like this relationship, you know, it could really go somewhere or it's already going somewhere.
You're happy. You're fulfilled. Your friends and your family. They love this person. And then out of nowhere, this kind of small feeling starts to creep in. It's this feeling of, is this person really the one? Is this part of our relationship normal? Should I be having these doubts?
Is this a sign we shouldn't be? be together. It can definitely send you spiraling in confusion and facing all of these annoying questions leaves you doubting whether it is your anxiety or your intuition about this relationship. And this, my lovely listeners, is something that we call relationship anxiety or relationship OCD. And for those of us in our 20s, when, you know, we're kind of experiencing our first really long-term, important relationships, it can be a real pain and it can really ruin otherwise perfect and magical situations and magical experiences. And it can also leave us in a real negative thought spiral. So today, we are going to break down exactly why this occurs,
why we have been taught all these false notions of what a perfect relationship should look like. And when you should be doubting your doubts rather than accepting them at face value, we also have the privilege to be joined by an incredible relationship. coach Rebecca Orr, who specialises in helping people find relationships that feel confident and secure. She is perfect for this episode. Welcome, Rebecca. Oh, thank you so much for having me. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. And you are hearing a little UK accent, everyone. We had to arrange this from across the oceans. And oh my gosh, the UK to Australian time zone is a violent change. Like there is no time that works. I have some Australian
clients and it's crazy. She's used to it then. But I'm honestly, I'm used to it. You're used to it. When I like heard what you have to say about relationship OCD, I was like, everyone in their 20s needs to hear this advice. So before we get into that advice, can you quickly introduce yourself to the listeners of the psychology of your 20s? Yeah, of course. So as said, I am Rebecca and I'm a relationship coach that specialises in helping people with anxieties and insecurities in their relationship. So what I do is help people kind of take back control of their brains, create relationships that feel secure and confident. And really, it's a lot about their relationship with themselves, being able to trust themselves, being able to manage their own minds, kind of challenge
those fearful thoughts that their brain is constantly offering to them. And yeah, and really just feel back in control. And the reason I got into doing this was because I spent the majority of my teenage years and my 20s just feeling absolutely terrified in relationships, just so, so scared all of the time. And this is why the work I do is so, so important to me because basically I went through my my own kind of journey with this work with seeking out, you know, expert help and listening to podcast and going to therapy and reading all the books and all these things. And, and all these things. things. And yeah, I finally found kind of a set of tools, a set of concepts, a structure that really helped me to get out of this kind of spiral. And yeah, that made me realize that I need
to help other people do this. So it's work that I'm really, really passionate about. And when I say I can relate to everyone I coach, it's literally like coaching a past version of me in every session. You know, you are the kind of like the kind of guess that I love having on the show when it's someone who is not only an expert, but has lived experience with the things we're talking about. Not to like hate on anyone who's trying to help people, but I just find that you can only get so deep if you haven't been through it yourself. Yeah. You can only really understand the extreme anxiety that comes with relationship OCD if you've
experienced it yourself. We have to talk about this topic, though, because some people may not be familiar with relationships, OCD, can you give me a brief description of what it is and maybe what it feels like? Also, something I need to bring up. It has OCD in the name, of course. But I think people, if you're thinking about the typical kind of OCD that we might talk about, it is quite different to what I'm assuming most people are imagining. So I'm sure you will confirm, deny all of those thoughts or explain them further. But yes, give us the basics of relationship OCD. R-O-CD, relationship OCD, is where people have obsessive, compulsive thinking in their intimate
relationships. So it's going to feel like intrusive thoughts of doubt and anxiety surrounding relationships. And of course, doubt in any relationship is normal. Of course it is. But people with R-O-CD find that the level of doubt, the level of doubt and anxiety is uncontrollable. And it feels really intrusive and it feels really distressing. And what that can look like is constantly debating if the relationship is right. It looks like a lot of ruminating. It looks like a lot of monitoring and checking how they feel. So do I feel in love now? Like, oh no, I just felt bored. What does that mean? Am I attracted to them enough? It's a lot of kind of monitoring how they feel. There's a lot of comparing. So comparing your relationship to other people's
relationships, what you see on TV, on films, social media. There can be a lot of kind of trying to control your partner, trying to kind of nitpick. You know, if we don't want them to be imperfect. You want them to do everything just right so that we don't have to feel any negative emotion or doubt. If we can make them do it just right, then we don't have to feel negative emotion, which we will end up spiraling on and thinking that means something terrible. So it can, it can mean that people can be a little bit, not in a malicious way, but that they kind of want to try and control and micromanage their partner a little bit. There can be a lot of ruminating about missing out. You know, am I missing out on someone better, being afraid to commit to someone just in case
it doesn't work out? And even to go as far as people might avoid committing to relationships at all because they're so afraid to experience this doubt and anxiety. So yeah, it can be a really hard thing to experience. And for me, although I coach a lot of people with R.OCD, what I really experienced myself is more kind of, kind of, I feel like there's two kinds of fears. There's like the fear of being left and then there's the fear of like, I'm not in the right relationship and, you know, this relationship is going to end. I might leave them. For me, I was much more afraid people were going to leave me. But I think the, the fears are so closely linked and I coach so many people with these intrusive doubts in their relationship.
And yeah, those were kind of the most common things that we see time and time again. So I'm sure some of your listeners can totally relate to at least one or two of those things. Oh, yeah. And you know what? Especially in our 20s when we're like, I just want to have this great big love. And I'm so young and this is the time when I'm meant to be meeting people and dating and exploring if I'm going to sink my time. into this relationship, it better be the right person and I better be 100% sure. And I'm going to say this, like, I'm in such an amazing relationship. I'm not 100% sure. I'm like, think I'm 99.9% there.
But you are always going to have doubts and I actually think that's important because it causes you to continue to examine your relationship and to continue to consciously say, I do want to be here. You know what I mean? I think if you never thought about your relationship, all, it becomes this passive thing. But we want to find the balance, right? I'm also assuming, from what you've described, that a lot of people do find that they end up self-sabotaging relationships, that a relation, like their relationship patterns may be quite self-destructive, that they have a lot of regret around leaving past relationships, missing that person, being unable to move on. Do you find that some of your clients will come to you and say,
there was this relationship I had and in hindsight it was perfect and I can't get them back. What am I going to do now? Like is that something that happens? Yeah, I have coached people that have been in that situation where as we start to unpack their patterns, they realize, oh wait, it wasn't them, that it wasn't the relationship. It was the problem. It was my brain. And that can be a moment where people start to feel loads of regret and kind of almost
shame around that. but I think it kind of plays into a little bit of what the kind of underlying thinking error is, which there can almost be this scarcity around it. Like there's this one right person for me. And I know we're going to come on to talking about the one, the idea of the one as well, but we almost have this idea that there's this one person for me, and they're predetermined. They're like a needle in the haystack that I need to go find.
And therefore, if I've missed them, then I've missed them, but they've gone. And I think a big part of snapping out of this, ROCD kind of mentality is there isn't one right person. There are just billions of imperfect humans on the planet that you could create amazing relationships with. If it didn't happen with that person in the past because your brain wasn't ready for it, you weren't in the place to have that or they weren't or maybe now you are, but they aren't, maybe they're now dating someone else. That doesn't mean you've missed, but you're one great chance for love. It means that, okay, that person, it wasn't the right time with that person. And there are other amazing people
that you can create a great relationship with. So I think for me, it's always coaching them through that scarcity mindset of like, it's like that kind of, there's, there's one slice of pizza left in the box or like there's one partner left on the shelf, like, and I've missed out. No, there are always more amazing partners that we can connect with. The world is, the world is not short of people. And there are billions of amazing, imperfect, flawed humans that we, we get to love. So yeah, I think that's the way I would coach them around that is really looking that scarcity mentality. The scarcity mentality in dating right now, as I'm sure many of my 20-something single people can attest, is wild. Like, it's absolutely wild. It just, I saw this, like,
TikTok the other day and it's like, if you met your partner on Hinge, you got like the last chopper out of Narm, like out of Vietnam. Like, you got the last lifeboat off the Titanic. Like, it's terrible. That's hilarious. I know. And I was like, gosh, no wonder people feel like they need to like, no wonder people feel like they can't leave bad relationships, but also the sense of doubt around choosing the wrong person because if you've chosen the wrong person, eventually you'll be single again and it just seems also terrible and bleak, which it isn't. But I'm jumping the gun because I want to ask you this one question. I so want to get some of our basics down Pat. Are there certain people who are more prone to our
OCD relationship OCD than others. Yeah, so I think there's so many things that can impact these kinds of thought patterns. And one is childhood experiences. You know, if you grew up in a family where maybe you saw a lot of kind of problematic behavior in a romantic relationship, you know, your mom and dad maybe, or maybe they went for a really painful divorce and that was really hard to witness, you know, our brains are always absorbing beliefs. And we can absorb these beliefs from childhood that relationships are scary and dangerous or relationships aren't safe. Relationships will end. Relationships are scary.
And so childhood experiences is a huge one. Social conditioning, which I know we've said as well, like all these messages we receive about, you know, how relationships should look, the Disney movies we watched, you know, the rom-coms we've seen, all this kind of social conditioning can really impact the way we think about it. But I think some people do just have more anxious tendencies than others due to their genes, their DNA. And it can be hard to pinpoint. And I think my advice for the clients is to worry less about why is my brain like this and focus more on how can I show up with compassion and care to work with what I've got. You know, if my brain is absorbed this from somewhere, who knows where, could have been childhood, could have been a Disney movie I
watching I was five and my brain just really latched on to it. Like, who knows, let's just meet you where you are and learn to guide ourselves through it. Oh, do you know how refreshing that take is? I love to examine the why, but I think that it's like, it's the why and the now. And you need to be able to distinguish them because the past, your genetics, your personality, none of it is, like, none of it is, I don't want to say incorrectable. none of it is going to determine everything. It's right. It's set in stone. Yeah. We can end up trapped in the story where we're like, well, because my dad cheated on my
mum five times, like now I'm really bad at relationships. And that's not me mocking anyone that says those kinds of things. I totally understand it. I've been there myself. But we can end up trapped in that story where we identify as I'm a person that's bad at relationships or I'm a person that can't commit because of this thing. And when we tell our brains that, our brain's just like, okay, we don't commit.
That's who we are. And there's no way out of that. So, yeah, I think just being able to recognize what might have contributed with compassion. And then, okay, now what? What are we doing from here? This is something I talk about a lot. Also just in my personal life with my friends, what is the story that you're telling yourself that is making your life less amazing than it could be?
Because each of us is telling ourselves a story. Maybe it's not about relationship OCD. Just think about it in general. That we're telling ourselves a story around how we're incapable. We're telling ourselves a story around how we don't deserve certain things about what people think about us, about the fact that our relationships are always going to fail. Again, I'm going to bring in a pop culture reference here, which I don't do that often, but there is so much pop culture references to relationship OCD when you look for them.
It's the song, The Prophecy by Taylor Swift. Have you heard this song? yes i was like yeah i'm guessing she has and it's the sense of like i don't know if you've listened to the song if you haven't it's such a beautiful song and it's basically like her talking about how she's deemed to always have her relationships fail and anyone who is anxiously attached anyone who struggles with relationship anxiety anyone who has just been you know unfortunate enough to have had too many relationships end and end up being lessons will relate to that song of feeling like it's a prophecy, this is set in stone, and it most certainly is not. And we've talked about
the story that we might tell ourselves. What about the story that society tells us? What are we told relationships should look like? And why do you find that sometimes unhealthy? Wow, I could talk for hours about this, but I'll try and streamline it a little bit for the sake of not sending everyone to sleep. But yeah, we have absorbed so. many messages from society, from, you know, even, you know, the parents, the caregivers, teachers, everyone that we've come into contact with, our brains are always listening, especially as children, we're always absorbing messages. And, you know, we're kind of sold the idea of romantic relationships saving us, you know, especially as women. And then this is one thing
I want to say as well is that I think a lot of women in particular suffer with REOCD because they've kind of been taught that their romantic relationship is a reflection of their work and value. I mean, and if we think about historically, you know, at one point, a woman's romantic relationship was literally her lifeline. She didn't have a bank account. She didn't have a job. She didn't have a place to live on her own. She couldn't buy property. A romantic partner was, was her lifeline. So although we're not living in that, thankfully, anymore, you know, it still trickled down where women really believe that their romantic partner is a reflection of their worth and value. if they don't have a romantic partner, it's because they aren't worthy and valuable in some way.
And if they do, that person is like this mirror of whether they are worthy and valuable. And so, yeah, we put a lot of pressure on our romantic relationships. And we often kind of think of them as coming along to save us. You know, if we're single, we think, oh, I'm going to get this person come along and they are going to be this amazing person that's going to come along and complete me. They're going to be the other half of me. They're going to be my soulmate, my one and only. and then my life will be happily ever after. And if we think of the Disney films that we've watched, think of rom-coms.
You know, we always see them running off into the sunset together. We don't see the after part of the happily ever after. You know, we don't see the part where Cinderella's sat around feeling a bit bored and frustrated because the prince has been late home every night that week. Or, you know, we don't see them maybe start scrolling on their phones, not having much to say to each other or the fact that they've maybe not had sex for a few weeks because, you know, they've been really tired. We don't see the realities of relationships really played out to us, even on social media,
you know, and this is just, you know, it's not kind of social media's fault, it's just the way that it is, but we don't post our lows, we only post the highs, we post the engagement photos, we post those gushy Valentine's posts when we're all dressed up. Of course we're not going to post the mundane moments where we're just sat. I'm like, oh, look at me, like sat with my partner having nothing to say. We're not going to post that. and the brain then subconsciously believes that those things don't exist. The boring, the mundane, the negative just doesn't exist.
So then when we experience it, we think, what has gone wrong? There must be something wrong. Yeah, I must not be normal. If I feel like, look at everyone else is so happy, so connected, out doing cute things, having a great time all the time. And I'm sat here feeling bored and, you know, maybe we're not doing anything this weekend. Something must be wrong. And so yeah, one of the expectations we have is for our relationships to be happy and blissful all of the time.
And we think our partners are supposed to fulfill every single need that we have. And this is one of the things that I was saying about kind of people monitoring their emotions because they kind of believed that relationships. And I was actually coaching someone last night who said the same thing that, well, relationships are supposed to be happy, right? And we were like, I said, well, yeah, you know, happiness is one emotion. You're feeling your relationship. But what if you're supposed to also feel other emotions? And it was like a, it was kind of like a light bulb moment for her where she was like, oh, she thought that happy was the one emotion she was supposed to feel.
Sorry, I realize I'm talking a lot now. I get excited about this. Oh, I love it, please. But yeah, yeah, so we end up if we do feel a negative emotion like annoyed, irritated, frustrated with our partners, we start to panic and think, I shouldn't be feeling that. You know, why am I feeling this way? This isn't normal.
I think we're just so scared of doing it wrong that we become hypervigilant. You know, we start comparing. Are we having sex enough compared to other couples? Are we going on enough date nights compared to other couples? As if there is just this one set normal and we just want to know that that exists so that we can then rest assured that we are doing it right.
So yeah, there's a whole lot of expectations to challenge. And I think that is one of the biggest things that we have to do with our OCD is really looking at looking at what is my unchecked story of how relationships should be. What is the reality? And, you know, and a question I like to ask people is, if you knew that that was just totally normal, would it be a problem? And for most of them are like, oh, no, if I knew that it was normal to sometimes go a few weeks without having sex, like, I don't know, it wouldn't be a big deal to me at all.
Like, people almost need permission for it to be normal. like it's okay. I think it's because relationships are so nuanced and complex and complicated and they're scary. Like being in love is scary. We look to be validated by what other people are doing because that provides us with some sense of confidence that we're doing it right. It's like cheating off the test of someone next to you thinking that they know what they're
doing and they don't actually. And when you were talking about that client, that, you know, I have to feel happy in a relationship and you're saying, well, what if your relationship is meant to teach you other things? You know, as humans, there was a study I read recently that we have access to 34,000 different kinds of emotions, distinct different emotional states. How boring would it be if your relationship only fulfilled one?
That means you would have 33,900,000, 950s. 99 other emotions, maybe 998, if we also include love, that you would have to find elsewhere. Yeah. That doesn't sound particularly enjoyable. Yeah. I love that you said that as well because one of the concepts I teach is called the 50-50. And it's this idea that life is supposed to be about the 50-50, the 50-50 of positive and negative emotion.
And no matter where you are, no matter where you live, no matter what job you do, your brain is going to create the 50-50. And I always think of like, you know, when you think of people that are rich and famous and have it all, that my brain goes to like the Kardashians, you only have to watch an episode of the Kardashians to see that they are living the 50-50. They have a lot of positive emotion, but boy, do they have negative emotion too. And they have money, they have cars, they have, you know, glamour, they have the big house, their brain is still creating the 50-50. They're going to feel bored, they're going to feel frustrated, they're going to feel irritated, they're going to feel disconnected sometimes. And it's really this reminder that it doesn't matter where you are,
what you're doing. You know, on my honeymoon in December, me and my wife were sat on the beach one day and we were both just in a terrible mood. And we both looked at each other. We were like, this really proves the idea of the 50-50 because we're literally on our honeymoon on a beach. In love. And we're both really irritated. Yeah, in love. And we were both really irritated. And we were like waiting for the boat to pick us up. And we were like, we were just in like a bad mood. And it's just this idea of no matter which partner you have, no matter who you pick, your brain is going to create the negative 50, which includes boredom, frustration, anxiety, irritation, all the things you said.
Like, it's going to give you the whole spectrum. And I think when we can know that, we can worry less about, okay, which right partner is going to give me the exit ramp off that human experience? Which right partner is going to come along and save me from that negative 50? And just which human do I want to enjoy? loving while knowing my brain's going to create all of the emotions no matter what. Yeah. I love the way you put that.
I absolutely love it. We're going to take a short break here. Let us have a little break for water, a little tea break, a thinking break. But we will return very, very shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hard. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and,
谢谢你把话说完。我觉得对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。欢迎在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方回听。欢迎收听我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了呼吁大家关注心理健康月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
以及与众多优秀嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in. And her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
加入我的新播客《The Hard Way》，和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《The Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这是一场长达数年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬，这里是《Love Trap》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Love Trap》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back with the wonderful, brilliant. Rebecca Orr to talk about relationship OCD. So, something I know people are thinking is, if my brain is going to create the 50-50 with anyone, when do I know what doubts to listen to and which ones to ignore? Because there are people who are just strictly not right for us. So do you have any tricks for telling the difference between an anxious thought and an actual doubt? Yeah. So there's a process that I would encourage people to try. And it basically
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方。好的，我们回来了，今天和我们在一起的是优秀且才华横溢的丽贝卡·奥尔，我们来聊聊关系强迫症（ROCD）。所以，我知道人们心里在想的一件事是：如果我的大脑会对任何人产生“百分之五十对百分之五十”的想法，我该什么时候知道哪些疑虑该听取，哪些该忽略呢？因为有些人确实在严格意义上不适合我们。所以你有什么绝招来辨别焦虑的想法和实际的疑虑吗？是的。所以，我鼓励大家尝试这样一个过程。它基本上
starts with self-soothing. Because in the moment where you feel triggered, as in anxious, you feel that kind of urgency, what we've got to remember is that your brain is seeing whatever the situation is as dangerous. Your brain thinks that this relationship ending is, is dangerous in some way. Or, you know, this partner not being right for you is dangerous. It's going to mean something bad. So it's sounding the alarm and you can think of it like maybe an overprotective guard dog or a faulty smoke alarm. I sometimes use that analogy. So your brain is sounding the alarm as if, you know, there's a lion about to attack you when really, okay, your partner just might not be a good match for you. You're not going to die. But so we've got to start with just kind of grounding ourselves because
从自我安抚开始。因为在你感到被触发的当下，也就是感到焦虑、感受到那种急迫感时，我们必须记住的是，你的大脑把当前的情况看作是危险的。你的大脑认为这段关系的结束在某种程度上是危险的。或者，你知道，这个伴侣不适合你也是危险的。这意味着会有不好的事情发生。所以它拉响了警报，你可以把它想象成一只过度保护的看门狗，或者一个故障的烟雾报警器。我有时会用这个比喻。所以你的大脑在拉响警报，就好像，你知道，有一头狮子正要攻击你，但实际上，好吧，你的partner可能只是不太适合你。你又不会死。但因此，我们必须从让我们自己平静下来开始，因为
when we're in that place of heightened anxiety or fear, the rational part of our brain, is not online. The prefrontal cortex, the part of our brain that is in charge of logical, rational thinking, completely offline, and it's the primitive brain doing all the talking. So in these moments, if you're feeling really triggered, you're having a lot of doubts. Just start by, first of all, observing the experience. So I like to do this by just shifting to the observer of my thought. So, okay, my brain is telling me this thought. Or, okay, I'm noticing my partner, you know, said this and my brain's making it mean this. Okay, I'm just noticing my brain is telling me this. So you notice it's kind of like you're shifting to observing the story.
当我们处于高度焦虑或恐惧的状态时，我们大脑的理性部分并没有联网。前额叶皮层，也就是负责逻辑、理性思考的大脑部分，完全下线了，是原始大脑在做所有的发言。所以在这些时刻，如果你感到真的被触发了，你有很多疑虑。首先，从观察你的体验开始。所以我喜欢通过转移到自己思想的观察者身份来做到这一点。所以，好吧，我的大脑正在告诉我这个想法。或者，好吧，我注意到我的伴侣，你知道，说了这个，而我的大脑把它解读成了这个意思。好吧，我只是注意到我的大脑在告诉我这个。所以你注意到它，这有点像你转变为去观察这个故事。
Then we've got to sit and ground ourselves back in our body. We've got to calm the body down. Again, and we're signaling to the primitive brain. It's okay, brain, we're safe. There's no lion. There's no tiger. We're actually safe. So there's a whole process I teach on kind of grounding in the body. But it really involves being willing to sit and feel the emotions. Feel the sensations of that anxiety. Just notice where they are. Take a breath around them. Notice how you can just coexist with them. They can't hurt you. And try and just be present with that experience without trying to rush to escape it. And the client I was coaching last night, we were talking about this. And she always feels like it like it's an emergency. She has to solve it right away. So if her brain offers her these
然后我们必须坐下来，把我们的身体重新锚定在当下。我们必须让身体平静下来。再次强调，我们在向原始大脑发出信号。没事的，大脑，我们很安全。没有狮子。没有老虎。我们其实很安全。所以我教过一整套关于如何在身体中进行锚定的流程。但它确实需要你愿意坐下来去感受这些情绪。去感受焦虑带来的感觉。只需注意到它们在哪里。围绕着它们做个呼吸。注意到你可以如何与它们共存。它们伤害不了你。并试着与那种体验共处，而不要急于逃避它。昨晚我辅导的客户，我们就在谈论这个。她总是觉得这就像是一场紧急情况。她必须马上解决它。所以如果她的大脑给她提供这些
doubts, she has to solve it. She has to know whether it's like, you know, right, wrong, go, what she's going to do? So we've been really working on, can she just sit and observe? Like, oh, okay, like I'm feeling this in my body. And this is the story my brain is telling me, okay, this isn't an emergency. This is just, you know, a thought and feeling I'm having. It's okay. When you do that, it's kind of like you're turning the volume down. So what felt like a nine out of ten on the anxious doubt, scary spiral scale is going to come down to like a four or a three or even lower. You can just bring your kind of, it's going to turn the volume down. it's going to bring the sensations down a little bit.
疑虑，她就必须解决它。她必须弄清楚这到底是，你知道的，对的、错的、走还是留，她该怎么做？所以我们一直在努力的是，她能只是坐下来观察吗？比如，噢，好吧，我的大脑里有这种感觉。这就是我的大脑告诉我的故事，好吧，这不是紧急情况。这只是，你知道的，我脑中的一个想法和感觉。没关系的。当你这样做时，这有点像你在把音量调小。所以，在那个关于焦虑疑虑、可怕的下坠螺旋的量表上，原本感觉像是十分之九的事情，会降到四分、三分甚至更低。你可以把你的，这会把音量调小。它会让那些感觉稍微平息一点。
They might not go completely, but it's going to just make them just kind of more like background noise. Yeah. From there, that's when you can really check. Is there an unchecked story here? Is there an expectation at play that I need to look at? So I always like to get my clients to separate out what are the facts versus what is the story.
它们可能不会完全消失，但它会使它们更像是背景噪音。是的。从那里开始，这才是你真正可以去检查的时候。这里有没有未经检验的故事？这里有没有一个我需要审视的期待在起作用？所以我总是喜欢让我的客户把事实与故事区分开来。
Just so they can check, is this something I want to keep thinking? So I had a client that would doubt whether her relationship was right whenever her and a harness sat in silence on the sofa scrolling on their phone. And so the fact was they were, they were sat in silence scrolling on their phones. And her thought, her story was, we should be more connected. We shouldn't ever feel bored. We should always have something to talk about. So we've got to challenge those expectations and stories. You know, is that really true that you should never feel bored ever just because you have a romantic partner? Like, why? You know, do you have to be in conversation all the time to love and care about someone? You know, is that really
这样他们就可以检查，这真的是我想继续想下去的事情吗？所以我曾有一位客户，每当她和男友安静地坐在沙发上刷手机时，她就会怀疑他们的关系是否合适。所以事实是，他们当时正安静地坐在沙发上刷手机。而她的想法，她的故事是：我们应该更有连接感。我们不应该感到无聊。我们应该总是有话说。所以我们必须挑战这些期待和故事。你知道，仅仅因为你有了浪漫的伴侣，就永远不该感到无聊，这真的是真的吗？为什么？你知道，为了爱一个人并在乎一个人，你必须时时刻刻都在聊天吗？你知道，这真的是
true, is it possible you can have nothing particular to say in that moment and still really get on with that person and think that's great? So it's kind of like really challenging those misconceptions, those expectations. Is there a shut at play? And you know, who said, who said that you should be doing this? Where did that come from? Was that something from childhood? Was that something from, you know, social media or the kind of Disney films you watched or, you know, rom-coms? So doing that first is important. because you might discover after going through that process that there's no issue, actually. It was just your brain, your fearful brain, sounding the alarm to try and protect you,
真的吗，有没有可能在那一刻你没有什么特别要说的话，但依然和那个人相处得很好，并觉得这很棒？所以这有点像真正去挑战那些误解、那些期待。这里有没有一个“应该”在起作用？你知道，谁说的，谁说过你应该这样做？这从哪里来的？那是童年时期的东西吗？那是来自，你知道的，社交媒体或是你看过的迪士尼电影，或者，你知道的，浪漫喜剧的东西？所以首先做这件事很重要。因为在经历了这个过程之后，你可能会发现其实根本没有问题。那只是你的大脑，你那个充满恐惧的大脑，在拉响警报试图保护你，
and actually it's not a problem. Other times you might discover that there are things that are a deal breaker, that maybe, although you've challenged the story, you still don't really like this thing, or there's something that maybe that goes against a value of yours that doesn't feel good in the relationship. And that's going to be so much easier to see when you're coming from a calm, rational place, and you've challenged those stories first. I love that where it's like, okay, we need to get back to that regulated, calm state before making any rash decisions. I also think in my experience, and I've done a whole episode on this called anxiety versus
而实际上这并不是什么问题。而在其他时候，你可能会发现确实存在一些不可妥协的底线，也许尽管你挑战了这个故事，你仍然真的不喜欢这件事，或者有什么东西违背了你的价值观，在关系中让你感觉不好。当你处于一个冷静、理性的状态，并且首先挑战了那些故事时，这一切将会变得容易看清得多。我非常喜欢这种说法，就像是，好吧，我们在做出任何轻率的决定之前，需要回到那个受调节的、平静的状态。我也认为根据我的经验，而且我曾为此做过一整集名为《焦虑与直觉》的节目，你对某事的直觉是不会要求你立刻给出答案的。你的焦虑是具有紧迫性的。你的焦虑想要一个加速的解决方案，
intuition, your intuition about something is not going to demand an answer from you right away. Your anxiety is urgent. Your anxiety wants an accelerated solution. so that it can return to an internal state of emotional homeostasis, your intuition will be like you make this decision in your own time. Yeah, it's a calm knowing rather than that anxious. Yeah, totally. Exactly.
这样它就可以回到内部情绪平衡的状态，而你的直觉会像是：你可以按照自己的节奏做出这个决定。是的，这是一种平静的知晓，而不是那种焦虑的。是的，完全是这样。没错。
And it all comes back to this. I also think there are some pretty obvious red flags, right? And I think that if you are continuously having this feeling of, oh, this just doesn't feel right. and it's making you miserable in other situations, like where it just won't go away and you are miserable because of it. And you've discussed it with that person. And it just isn't being resolved.
这一切都归结于此。我也认为有一些相当明显的危险信号，对吧？我认为如果你不断地有这种感觉，即“哦，这感觉就是不对”，并且它在其他情况下让你感到痛苦，比如这种感觉挥之不去，而你为此感到痛苦。并且你已经和那个人讨论过了。但它就是没有得到解决。
Like there is a genuine need that is not being met for you. It's like sitting on your phone with your partner. If you are sitting on the couch and you're sitting in silence and you're kind of like, I actually kind of enjoy this, but maybe we shouldn't be doing this, that's probably an anxious thought. But if you're sitting on the couch and you turn to your partner and say, hey, I actually really would want us to, I really want to connect right now.
就像有一种真正的需求没有得到满足。这就好比和伴侣一起坐在手机前。如果你坐在沙发上，你们静静地坐着，而你的心里其实觉得，我其实挺享受这一刻的，但也许我们不该这样，这可能是一个焦虑的想法。但如果你坐在沙发上，你转向你的伴侣说，嘿，我其实真的很想让我们，我真的很想现在有连接感。
And they're like, no, I don't want to. Leave me alone. And they're not listening to you. Yeah. Like that, I think that is an actual doubt. It's something that you can't collaborate through. It's something that like, if there's going to be this 50, 50, you want a team member. You want someone who actually can collaborate with and compromise with.
而他们却说，不，我不想。别烦我。而且他们根本不听你说话。是的。就像那样，我认为那才是一个真正的疑虑。那是你无法通过合作来解决的事情。那是那种，如果将来的关系要是百分之五十对百分之五十的话，你会想要一个队友。你会想要一个真正能与你合作和妥协的人。
If that's not them, I think it's not going to work. What are some, yeah. Sorry. I'm sorry. I was just going to say, one of the things I teach as well is this idea of the want match. And it's this idea that we have different wants in a relationship. And some people will match those and some people won't.
如果那个人不是这样，我认为这段关系是行不通的。有什么，是的。抱歉。抱歉。我只是想说，我所教导的其中一个概念就是“需求匹配”这个理念。这个理念是，我们在一段关系中有不同的需求。有些人会与这些需求相匹配，而有些人则不会。
So, you know, you might have a want for a partner that's really physically affectionate. And they might be someone that doesn't like physical affection. Well, that's not a want match then. And I think, yeah, when we can really, it's kind of like when we can calm the overprotective guard dog down. Like, it's okay, buddy. It's okay. We're going to be all right. we can then drop into that, well, what are the deal breaker to me? What is the kind of partner I want?
所以，你知道，你可能希望一个伴侣在身体上非常亲密。而他们可能是一个不喜欢身体亲密的人。好吧，那这就不是需求匹配了。我想，是的，当我们真的能够，这有点像当我们能够让那个过度保护的看门狗平静下来。就像，没关系，伙计。没事的。我们会好起来的。我们就可以进入到那一层：对我的底线是什么？我想要的伴侣是怎样的？
You know, no partner is going to be perfect. The person isn't going to do it perfectly all the time, but are we aligned with our values and our want matches? You know, do we want the same things out of a relationship? If this person wants to, you know, never really have sex, that's what they want, but you have a, you know, you have a really strong sex drive and sex is really important to you. Okay, that might not be a want match and that's okay too. So yeah, I love that you said that. And I think you're right, when we can kind of drop into that calmness, it becomes so much easier to decipher. And if you have respect for the other person, it's like, I just feel like that is also, it's just such a big thing. And if there's no respect, that is a deal breaker you should listen to.
你知道，没有哪个伴侣是完美的。对方不可能在所有时间都做到完美，但我们的价值观和需求匹配是一致的吗？你知道，我们对一段关系有着相同的期望吗？如果这个人想要，你知道，基本上不怎么过性生活，那是他们想要的，但你拥有，你知道，你有着非常强烈的性欲，并且性对你来说真的很重要。好吧，那可能就不是需求匹配，这也是可以接受的。所以，是的，我非常喜欢你刚才说的话。而且我想你是对的，当我们能够进入那种平静状态时，去辨别事情就会变得容易得多。如果你对另一个人有尊重，我觉得这也是，这是一个非常重大的事情。如果缺乏尊重，那就是一个你应该听从的底线。
I also believe, and you can correct me on this because you're the expert, but this is my personal opinion. I also believe that you don't have to address your doubts right now if you feel comfortable and stable. You know what I mean? Like the anxiety again is this urgent thing. I find that sometimes with my relationship at OCD I'm like, what if I feel differently in five years? And then I've wasted all this time and there was something five years ago that I didn't see and we're five years down the line and I ignored it and oh my God now my whole life is over. I think that is the story we've got a challenge as well. And sorry to cut in that. That is what I hear so much. When people say, I'm so worried that I'm going to regret this in five years time, I think it's so,
我也相信，你可以纠正我，因为你是专家，但这只是我个人的意见。我也相信，如果你感到舒适和稳定，你现在并不一定要去解决你的疑虑。你知道我的意思吗？焦虑又一次表现为一件十万火急的事情。我发现有时我的关系强迫症（R-OCD）会让我觉得：如果我五年后的感觉变了怎么办？然后我就浪费了所有的精力和时间，而五年前有一些我没有看到的迹象，结果五年后我们走到了这一步，而我当时忽视了它，天哪，现在我的整个人生都完了。我认为这也是我们必须去挑战的故事。抱歉打断一下。这正是我经常听到的。当人们说，我太担心五年后我会后悔时，我觉得这太，
it's so interesting because if we think about, your brain is constantly telling you stories. And basically in those moments, we're saying, I'm afraid that in five years time, my brain might tell me the story that I've wasted time. And so I'm really afraid today that my brain is going to say something to me in five years time that I won't like. But we forget that in five years time, we get to decide whether we believe that. And I think, this is why one of the things I was think of RCD is we've got to really look at what our brain is so afraid of underneath this all. Like, okay, if you are in this relationship and it ends in five years time, what is scary about that? And I think, you know, there's that thought you said,
这太有趣了，如果我们仔细想想，你的大脑一直在对你编造故事。基本上在那些时刻，我们是在说：我害怕五年后，我的大脑可能会告诉我一个“我浪费了时间”的故事。所以我今天真的很害怕五年后我的大脑会对我说出一些我不喜欢的话。但我们忘记了，在五年后，我们有权决定是否相信它。我认为，这就是为什么对于RCD，我常想的一点是：我们必须真正审视这一切背后，我们的大脑究竟在害怕什么。好吧，如果你在这段关系中，并且它在五年后结束了，这有什么可怕的？我想，你知道，正如你刚才提到的那个想法，
well, it means I've wasted time. That's not actually a fact. That is totally an optional way to think. And, you know, I always think I got married last year and I hope we're going to stay together forever. but if in five years time, we don't. We break up for whatever reason. I'm never going to think, oh, I wasted time. That was the wrong relationship. And now I need to beat myself up for that. I'm going to think, no, that was the total right decision for me in that moment.
嗯，这意味着我浪费了时间。这其实并不是一个事实。这完全是一种可选的思考方式。而且，我总是想，我去年结婚了，我希望我们能永远在一起。但如果在五年后，我们没有。无论出于什么原因我们分手了，我绝不会想，哦，我浪费了时间。那是错误的关系。现在我需要为此痛打自己一顿。我会想，不，在那一刻，这对我来说绝对是正确的决定。
And that was a beautiful relationship. And if it ends in five years time, I get to go and create another great relationship. And I think that is really what we need to look at. You know, what is it that you're afraid of? Is it that you're going to tell yourself you chose wrong? if this relationship ends? Is it that you don't believe you could handle the breakup? Is it a fear of getting divorced?
那是一段美好的关系。如果它在五年后结束，我还可以去创造另一段美好的关系。而我认为这正是我们需要去审视的。你知道，你到底在害怕什么？是害怕如果这段关系结束，你会告诉自己你选错了人？是害怕你觉得自己无法应对分手？是对离婚的恐惧？
Is it, you know, that you think that you then won't be able to meet anyone else at a certain age? Because I think we almost need to be willing for our relationships to end and know that we can handle them. But for so many of us, we see the idea of a relationship ending is failure. So we think, okay, in order for me to see this as a success and believe I'm good at relationships and I'm doing it right, this relationship has to last. forever. So we almost then start to work backwards and we're like, okay, well, how do I know that this person's going to be my forever person? Well, then I need to make sure that we never argue. And then we start to look for all these red flags and it just, it ruins our experience of it. Versus what if it didn't need to last forever necessarily? And again, I'm married. It's not me saying
还是说，你知道，你认为到了某个特定的年龄，你就再也遇不到其他人了？因为我认为我们几乎需要做好让关系结束的准备，并知道我们能够应对它。但对于我们中的许多人来说，把关系结束视为一种失败。所以我们认为，好吧，为了让我认为这是一次成功，并且相信我很擅长处理关系，而且我做得对，这段关系必须永远持续下去。所以我们几乎开始倒推，然后我们就会想，好吧，我怎么知道这个人会是我的一生挚伴？那么我需要确保我们永远不争吵。然后我们开始寻找所有这些危险信号，这简直毁了我们的体验。而如果我们想：它难道非得永远持续下去不可吗？再说一次，我已经结婚了。这并不是说
that I don't want my marriage to last forever. I'd love if it did. But I'm open to the possibility that if it ended, I could be okay. And I wouldn't beat myself up. I wouldn't make it mean I failed. It wouldn't be a failed relationship. It would be a relationship that lasted, however long it lasted. So I don't know what you think of that and what that brings up for you, but that for me is a really kind of important piece of this as well. I'll tell you what I think about that. Absolutely amazing advice. I think that's incredible advice. And I think that that is going to change the brain chemistry of a lot of people listening because it is absolutely true. It's like just because a relationship doesn't last forever, doesn't mean it wasn't beautiful, doesn't mean it wasn't right then.
我不希望我的婚姻持续到永远。如果能的话，我当然乐意。但我对这种可能性持开放态度：即使它结束了，我也能过得很好。而且我不会责怪自己。我不会认为这意味着我失败了。这不会是一段失败的关系。这将是一段持续了它该持续多久的关系。所以，我不知道你对此怎么看，这带给你什么样的感受，但对我来说，这也是其中非常重要的一个部分。我来告诉你我对这番话的看法。绝对是精彩绝伦的建议。我认为这是不可思议的建议。而且我认为这将改变许多听众的大脑化学机制，因为这绝对是真理。这就好像，仅仅因为一段关系没有持续到永远，并不意味着它不美好，也不意味着它在当时是不对的。
And I think it's so funny, you've just unlocked this in me of like maybe I think that all that our doubts are, all that our anxiety is, is our brain trying to have some insurance against future suffering. Yes, that's it. It's just like, okay, well, if I worry about this, this is like my insurance. This is like, you know, stop this. I'm sorry, but your anxiety is going to do nothing to stop you from suffering in the future. it's just going to make you suffer now. And again, there's this huge study in psychology that basically says, we tend to over-dramatize or intensify how we think we'll feel in the future.
而且我觉得太有趣了，你刚刚在我内心打开了这样一把锁：也许我认为我们所有的疑虑，我们所有的焦虑，不过是大脑试图为未来的痛苦购买一份保险。是的，就是这样。这就像是，好吧，如果我为此担忧，这就好比我的保险。这就像是，你知道，停止吧。对不起，你的焦虑对阻止你未来遭受痛苦毫无用处，它只会让你现在就遭受痛苦。再说一次，心理学中有一项重大研究基本上表明：我们往往会过度戏剧化或强化我们在未来会有什么感觉。
So you're sitting here right now and you're saying, well, if I don't get the dream job now in 10 years, I'm going to feel so terrible. Actually, they've done studies on this and they've found most of the time people actually feel pretty neutral. we over-exaggerate how we think we'll feel in the future. And this is the same thing with relationship OCD. Your relationship doesn't work out. It is going to be devastating. But it's not going to, your life isn't going to be over.
所以你现在坐在这里，你说，好吧，如果我现在找不到理想的工作，10年後我会感觉太糟糕了。实际上，他们对此做过研究，发现大多数时候人们其实感觉相当中立。我们夸大了我们认为自己在未来会有什么感觉。关系强迫症也是如此。你的关系没有成功。这会是毁灭性的。但它不会，你的人生不会就此结束。
You will be fine. People, so many people have made this pilgrimage, have had relationships that have failed. And they have thought it was absolutely perfect. So your anxiety doesn't mean one thing or the other. It's just, again, this insurance. But I want to ask us, this follow-up question, which is you're sitting here, you're doubting your relationship,
你会好起来的。人们，有那么多人都经历过这段朝圣之旅，都经历过失败的感情。而他们曾经认为那是绝对完美的。所以你的焦虑并不意味着什么。它只是，再次强调，这只是一份保险。但我想要问我们随后的这个问题，那就是你坐在这里，你对你的关系感到怀疑，
you're with this amazing person, how do you deal with the guilt of that? Do you, the guilt of like, well, if I'm having doubts, maybe they are better off without me. Yeah. Oh, that's so, so common as well. And, yeah, there's so much shame and guilt around this. And yeah, I think the most important thing to remember is that you aren't your thoughts. So the thoughts you have of doubt of judgment towards your partner, of doubting if you love them enough, of doubting whether they're right for you. You're not those thoughts. You're just the observer of those thoughts. Those thoughts are just random sentences that your brain offers you. And your brain works through repetition. So the fact that they come up so often is just because those are the ones you've
你和这个了不起的人在一起，你该如何处理由此产生的内疚感？你是否，那种内疚感就像是，如果我有疑虑，也许他们没有我会过得更好。是的。哦，这也是非常非常普遍的。而且，是的，这背后有很多羞耻感和内疚感。是的，我认为最重要的一点是要记住：你不是你的想法。所以你对伴侣产生怀疑、产生批判的想法，怀疑你是否足够爱他们，怀疑他们是否真的适合你。你不是那些想法。你只是那些想法的观察者。那些想法只是你的大脑提供给你的随机句子。而你的大脑是通过重复来运作的。所以它们之所以经常出现，只是因为这些是你的大脑
been practicing for so, so long. They're like your brains, it's like a radio station that loves to play the same three songs. Like your brain is going to keep. offering you the same thoughts that it loves to play the most. And that's all these thoughts are. They're just, they've been programmed into your brain from so many places, maybe past experiences, maybe messages from society, maybe, you know, early traumas that you had or just these fears and doubts about what it would mean if the relationship ended. You know, that is what created these thoughts. So it's kind of remembering that you just get to observe the thoughts. You don't need to beat yourself up for the thoughts being there. And, you know, having those doubts isn't a sign that
练习了非常非常久的想法。它们就像是你的大脑，就像是一个喜欢播放那三首老歌的广播电台。你的大脑会一直不断地向你提供它最喜欢播放的想法。这些想法全部就是这样。它们是通过很多途径被编程进你的大脑的，也许是过去的经验，也许来自社会的讯息，也许是，你知道的，你早年经历的创伤，或者只是关于关系结束意味着什么的恐惧和疑虑。你知道，正是这些创造了这些想法。所以这有点像提醒自己，你只需要去观察这些想法。你不需要因为这些想法的存在而惩罚自己。而且，你知道，有这些疑虑并不是一个迹象，
you're a mean, unloving person or even that you don't love your partner, it's just a sign that your brain has been trained to think in a certain way about relationships right now. So I would always say if you notice you're feeling guilt, if you're shaming yourself, try and shift to some self-compassion of like, I'm just a human with a very normal human brain and that's okay. You know, my fears and doubt aren't me. I'm just the observer of them. That's okay. There's a new therapeutic practice called radical self-compassion that I came across a few years ago just like change my life it's like you can on you can promise to unconditionally love someone else why can't you promise to unconditionally love yourself yeah yeah that's completely possible
表明你是一个刻薄的、缺乏爱心的人，甚至不代表你不爱你的伴侣，这只说明你的大脑现在已经被训练成以某种特定的方式来看待亲密关系。所以我总是说，如果你注意到自己感到了内疚，如果你在羞耻，试着转向一些自我同情，比如：我只是一个拥有非常普通的人类大脑的人，这没关系。你知道，我的恐惧和疑虑并不代表我。我只是它们的观察者。没关系。几年前我接触到了一种新的治疗实践，叫做“激进自我同情”，它真的改变了我的生活。就像你可以承诺无条件地爱另一个人一样，为什么你不能承诺无条件地爱自己呢？是的，是的，那完全是可能的。
like it's also coming back to this you know that's a term oCD is in this is in relationhip oCD is defined in large part by intrusive thoughts that we feel like we don't have control over Yeah. That really aligns with this guilt, this sense of like, why am I thinking this? I must be a bad person. And people with just, you know, regular OCD will find that a lot. Like, why am I thinking about, why am I thinking about crashing this car? Why am I suddenly thinking these terrible things?
就像这也回到了这一点，你知道，强迫症（OCD）的一个术语，在关系强迫症（ROCD）中，很大程度上是由我们觉得无法控制的闯入性想法所定义的。是的。这确实与这种内疚感、这种“我为什么会这样想？我一定是个坏人”的感觉高度契合。而患有，你知道的，常规强迫症的人也会经常有这种感觉。比如，我为什么会想，我为什么会想要把这辆车撞毁？为什么我突然会冒出这些可怕的想法？
This means something about me. And what you're saying is, you know, it doesn't, which I think is really, really beautiful. Yeah, it totally doesn't. It's just the way your brain has been trained to think right now. And that's okay. You can just be, it's almost like you can think. think of your brain as the separate entity from you. Like you can use different analogies, whether you want to think of it like a scared,
这一定说明了我身上的某些问题。而你所说的是，你知道，其实并没有，我认为这真的非常非常美妙。是的，完全没有。这只是你的大脑现在被训练成的一种思考方式。没关系。你完全可以，这几乎就像你可以思考。把你的大脑当作一个与你独立的实体。你可以使用不同的比喻，不管你想把它比作一个害怕的、
frightened animal, like a little toddler, you know, like you're the parent of it, like whatever analogy works for you. But you want to remember that you are the manager of your mind. You're not your mind. And really changing your relationship to it is so important. If every time your brain says something to you, you freak out and take it super seriously, or you beat yourself up for having it or you start to scream at it and why are you like this?
受惊的动物，还是一个蹒跚学步的小孩，你知道，就像你是它的家长一样，无论什么比喻对你管用。但你要记住，你是你心智的管理者。你不是你的心智。真正改变你与它的关系是非常重要的。如果每次你的大脑对你说什么时，你都吓坏了并且非常认真地对待它，或者你因为它的出现而责备自己，或者你开始对它尖叫：你为什么会这样？
You know, that's not going to be a very great way of managing it versus. is calmly being able to observe what it's saying and guide it to where you want it to go. Again, such beautiful advice. We're going to take one more short break. And when we return, we've got some wonderful listener questions. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
你知道，这并不是管理它的好方法。而冷静地去观察它在说什么，并引导它去你想去的地方，才是正确的。再次强调，这是如此美妙的建议。我们要进行最后一个短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我们将解答一些听众的精彩提问。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上担心的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更
fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
充实、更健康的个体。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什和小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会带你回顾历史，剖析当时的发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那一切的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客的节目，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for Black.
需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我觉得没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人
people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。欢迎在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方回听。欢迎收听我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了呼吁大家关注心理健康月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多优秀嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
已经拥有了它，而我们却还在追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在盯着记分牌，生活成了关于输赢的较量，史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？
or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。完全正确，这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我的新播客《The Hard Way》，和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《The Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这是一场长达数年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincolini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬，这里是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, Rebecca, this is something I've been doing recently where, you know, there are just so many niche questions that people have. for me out there about specific topics and I want to make sure that we cover everything that they ask. So I've got four listener questions for you today. Actually three listener questions and one bonus question for me. So I'm going to tell you those right now. Starting with this first question, which is coming from Emma, I feel like I'm totally madly in love with my partner and we have a beautiful relationship except for one thing. I feel like we cannot communicate and we're always having fights slash tension over the same things over and over again.
在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Love Trap》播客，Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方。好的，丽贝卡，这是我最近一直在做的事情，你知道，人们对特定话题有着许许多多小众的问题，我想确保我们涵盖了他们问的所有问题。所以我今天为你准备了四个听众提问。实际上是三个听众提问加上一个专门为我准备的加分问题。所以我现在就把它们告诉你。从第一个问题开始，这是艾玛发来的：我觉得我和我的伴侣疯狂地坠入爱河，我们有一段美好的关系，除了有一件事。我觉得我们无法沟通，我们总是因为同样的事情一遍又一遍地争吵/产生紧张关系。
Should I break up with them or do I just accept this as a flaw that they will always have and live with it? Yeah, that's an interesting question. And I think it was kind of hard for me to give an answer in the sense of knowing more about the context of the situation would be really important. But also, there is no right answer. You know, there's no expert out there that can tell you what relationship is right for you or when to stay or when to go.
我是应该和他们分手，还是把这当作他们永远会有的一个缺点去接受并与之共存？是的，这是一个有趣的问题。而且我觉得我很难给出一个答案，因为了解更多关于这种情况的背景信息非常重要。同时，也没有所谓的标准答案。你知道，外面没有任何专家能告诉你哪种关系对你来说是正确的，或者何时该留下，何时该离开。
That's never my job. But I think before you make a decision to leave or staying, it's just to do some real self-reflection on your own thoughts and feelings and the way you're showing up. Because if you do decide to leave, this can just be a really great kind of opportunity for you to take back control of who you are in relationships. So, you know, noticing, okay, what is the pattern in this communication?
这从来都不是我的工作。但我认为在做出去留决定之前，真正要做的是对你自己的想法、感受以及你呈现自我的方式进行一些真正的自我反思。因为如果你确实决定离开，这可以成为一个非常好的机会，让你重新掌控自己在亲密关系中的身份。所以，你知道，去注意到，好吧，这种沟通中的模式是什么？
Is it that I say something, that they say something, and then, you know, I get defensive, then they get defensive. Like, we want to just look at what is going on and really come back to owning your side of it. You know, okay, well, what, how are you approaching conversations? What is the feelings you're having and what are the reoccurring thoughts driving that? You know, do you keep making him sighing, enduring an argument, mean he is unbothered or like, whatever? And can we just, let's just challenge some of that so we can see, is there a different way to
是我说了什么，他们说了什么，然后，你知道，我开始防御，然后他们开始防御。我们想要审视到底发生了什么，并真正回归到承担你自己的那部分责任上。你知道，好吧，那么，你是如何对待对话的？你有什么样的感受，是什么样的重复想法在驱动着这些感受？你知道，在争论期间，你是否不断认为他叹气就意味着他毫不在乎，或者是别的什么？我们能不能，让我们挑战其中的一部分，以便我们看看，有没有一种不同的方式
navigate these moments that might turn the volume down on them completely, that might make it less of a problem. So again, that's really hard to just coach on in and just a short, pithy answer on a podcast. But I would do some work on that, really looking at, okay, what are my thoughts and feelings during these situations? And how do those thoughts and feelings have me showing up? And is that intentional? Am I really showing up as my intentional, highest self in these moment. And if not, no, there's no shame there. We all, we all struggle with that from time to time, but spend a moment just trying to work on that for yourself. And I always advise getting curious about what might be going on in our partner's brain too. You know, if your partner keeps
来度过这些时刻，从而彻底降低它们的音量，让它们不再成为一个大问题。所以再次强调，要在播客里通过一个简短精炼的回答来提供指导真的很困难。但我会在这方面做一些工作，真正审视：好吧，在这些情况下，我的想法和感受是什么？这些想法和感受如何影响我的表现？这是有意为之的吗？在这些时刻，我真的展现出我有意图的、最好的自我了吗？如果没有，不，这没什么好羞耻的。我们所有人，我们所有人偶尔都会为此苦恼，但请花一点时间试着为自己解决这个问题。我总是建议对伴侣大脑中可能发生的事情也保持好奇心。你知道，如果你的伴侣对某事总是做出同样的反应，让我们保持好奇。你知道，那对他们来说可能意味着什么？你知道，他们是不是每次听到你说的某些话，都将其解读为“他们不够好”？我和我妻子在刚开始恋爱时就有过这种情况。每当我针对某事给出一些反馈或批评时，她就会变得非常具有防御性。当我带着这种好奇心去探索，甚至对她保持好奇——“当我那样说时，你心里浮现的是什么？你心里在想什么？”时，结果发现她以为我在说她是一个糟糕的伴侣。我根本没有那个意思，但那是她的大脑所听到的。所以我想我们可以带入这种好奇心，然后看看会从中发现什么。但是，是的。
having the same response to something, let's get curious. You know, what might that be about for them? You know, do they keep hearing something you're saying and interpreting it as, um, they're not good enough? You know, me and my wife had this at the start of our relationship. Whenever I kind of kind of gave some feedback or some criticism on something, she'd get very defensive. And when I kind of dropped into that curiosity and I even got curious with her about, you know, what is it that comes up for you when I say that? What's going on for you? It was that she thought I was saying she was a bad part. And I wasn't saying that at all, but that was what her brain was hearing. So I think we can bring that curiosity and and then see what comes out with that. But yeah,
对某事产生相同的反应时，让我们保持好奇。你知道，对他们来说这可能是因为什么呢？你知道，他们是不是一直在听你说的某句话，并将其解读为，嗯，他们不够好？你知道，我和我妻子在恋爱初期就遇到过这种情况。每当我提出某种反馈或批评时，她都会非常防备。当我放下身段去好奇，甚至和她一起好奇时——你知道，当我那样说时，你心里会浮现出什么感觉？你经历了什么？结果发现，她以为我在说她是一个糟糕的伴侣。我根本没那个意思，但她的脑海里听到的就是这个。所以我觉得我们可以保持这种好奇心，然后看看会带来什么结果。不过，是的，
there's going to be at some point where you've really worked on yourself in it. You know you're doing your best. You're showing up with your best self. And the other person isn't able to meet you where you want them to be or that they're not able to to kind of have the same values with you in terms of communication and and openness or, you know, emotional regulation, whatever it is. And I think, yeah, sometimes it's accepting that, okay, this is the person for who they are. This is who they are. Is this someone I want to commit to loving for the good, the bad, the ugly? I love that advice. Our second question comes from a listener called Sean. Sean asks, is there a correlation between relationship OCD
总会走到这样一个阶段，你已经真正为自己努力过了，你知道自己正在尽力，你也拿出了最好的状态。然而对方却无法在你想让他们到达的地方回应你，或者他们在沟通、开放程度，或者情感调节等价值观上无法与你保持一致，无论具体是什么。我觉得，有时候就是要接受这一点：好吧，这个人就是这样，他就是这样的人。这真的是我想承诺去爱的人吗？无论是他的优点、缺点还是糟糕的一面？我太喜欢这个建议了。我们的第二个问题来自一位叫肖恩的听众。肖恩问：强迫症（ROCD）和焦虑型依附风格之间
and an anxious attachment style? I mean, yeah, I would definitely say so. I think with anyone with an anxious attachment style, their brain is kind of programmed to see relationships is dangerous, unsafe. They think that how this person behaves will either create safety or, you know, danger. So they are constantly monitoring, you know, what's this person doing? What does it mean about me if they leave me? What does it mean about me if they, you know, don't, they're not as interested anymore? And, and there's this kind of focus on the other person to create this inner feeling of safety and security. Totally, of course, then relates to our OCD because it's kind of the same fixation. The brain is seeing that thing outside of you, that person, that relationship, as either safe
是否存在某种关联？我的意思是，是的，我绝对会这么说。我认为对于任何有焦虑型依附风格的人来说，他们的大脑似乎被编程为将亲密关系视为危险和不安全的东西。他们认为这个人的行为要么会带来安全感，要么会带来危险。所以他们一直在监控：这个人现在在做什么？如果他们离开我，这对我意味着什么？如果他们不再那么感兴趣了，这对我又意味着什么？而且，人们往往会将这种焦点放在对方身上，希望借此在内心创造一种安全感。当然，这自然就与我们的强迫症联系在一起了，因为这是一种相似的执念。大脑把外部的事物、那个人、那段关系看作是安全的
or dangerous and trying to work out which it is and kind of create safety from it. So yeah, I definitely think there's a there's a correlation there and for me i i think whether it's r oCD whether it's anxious attachment it's really coming back to looking at your internal experience rather than trying to focus on the external rather than focusing on what is my partner doing or not doing it's okay what are the thoughts and feelings i'm having and what is that bringing up like what is whatever's going on out here bringing up within me um because that's where the safety and security is actually created. It's never created by the thing outside of us. It's created by our own thoughts and the beliefs we have. So yeah, I hope that answers that
还是危险的，并试图搞清楚到底是哪一种，从而从中获得安全感。所以，是的，我绝对认为这两者之间存在关联。对我而言，无论是强迫症还是焦虑型依附，真正关键的还是要回到审视你的内在体验上来，而不是试图去关注外部。不要去纠结伴侣在做什么或没做什么，而是去想：我现在有什么想法和感受？外面正在发生的一切在我内心引发了什么？因为安全感和归属感实际上正是从这里产生的。它从来不是由我们外部的事物创造的，而是由我们自己的想法和信念所创造的。所以，希望这回答了那个
question. There's definitely a correlation. And yeah, coming back to whichever it is, getting curious about your internal experience is really important. Yeah, excellent advice. So this is the final listener question. My relationship OCD is so bad that I cannot go more than a day without thinking that I should break up with my partner. I love them, but some part of me really just wants a break from my own thoughts. Would you recommend taking some time away just to get my relationship OCD under order or should I stick it out and work with them? It's a really good question.
问题。这两者绝对是有关联的。而且，无论具体情况如何，回过头来对你的内在体验保持好奇是非常重要的。是的，太棒的建议了。那么，这是最后一位听众的问题。我的关系强迫症太严重了，几乎过不了一天，我就觉得我应该和伴侣分手。我爱他们，但内心深处真的只是想从自己的思绪中解脱出来。你建议花点时间分开一段时间来理清我的关系强迫症，还是应该坚持下去并和他们一起面对？这是一个非常好的问题。
And again, I want to say that there's no right or wrong. if you feel like you just really need a break, do it. You know, you know what's right for you. Let yourself be the guide of that. But one thing I will say is that often when we're experiencing an emotion we don't like, like anxiety, we think the solution is to remove the external thing that we're blaming for causing it. So with RECD, we think anxious attachment, it's the partner. We think, let's remove them and then I won't have to have these thoughts and feelings.
再次说明，我想说的是，这并没有绝对的对与错。如果你觉得你真的需要休息一下，那就去做吧。你知道什么对你才是正确的，让自己成为自己的向导。但我要说的一点是，通常当我们经历像焦虑这样我们不喜欢的情绪时，我们认为的解决方案是移除那个被我们归咎为引发该情绪的外部事物。所以面对关系强迫症，当我们想到焦虑型依附时，就会觉得问题出在伴侣身上。我们会想：把他们移开，然后我就不用再有这些想法和感受了。
And there's some truth in that, you know, if that's the thing that triggers the thoughts and feelings, okay, you're probably going to get some relief. But what we don't really realize is that, well, those thoughts and feelings are still going to be there the minute we go back to the relationship or the minute we start another relationship. You know, I've seen so many people leave relationships thinking, okay, this partner was the problem, I'm going to leave. And then they have the same anxious, doubtful thoughts in the next one.
这里面确实有一定道理，你知道的，如果那正是触发想法和感受的根源，好吧，你可能确实会得到一些缓解。但我们真正没有意识到的是，嗯，当我们回到那段关系中，或者当我们开始另一段关系时，那些想法和感受其实依然会存在。你知道的，我见过太多人离开一段关系，心想：好吧，这个伴侣就是问题所在，我要离开。然后他们在下一段关系中又有了同样的焦虑和怀疑的想法。
And they're like, oh, damn it, like, turns out changing the partner didn't really work. So my advice, if you feel like you're able, if you don't feel like, you know, you're at a real burntout place with it, that you just. need the break, take that if you need it. But I would also consider what if instead of trying to escape the thoughts, what if I could work on changing my relationship to them? So if your brain keeps offering you the thought, this relationship is wrong for me, I should end this relationship, you want to start changing your relationship to that thought. So when it comes up, it can be like, oh, there's my brain's favorite story again. I'm noticing my brain is offering me that story again
他们会想：哦，见鬼，原来换掉伴侣并没有真正起作用。所以我的建议是，如果你觉得有能力，如果你并没有处于一种精疲力竭的状态，并且真的需要休息，那需要的话就休息一下。但我也建议你思考一下：如果我不去试图逃避这些想法，而是试着改变我与它们的关系会怎样？所以，如果你的大脑一直在向你灌输“这段关系不适合我，我应该结束它”这种想法，你要做的是开始改变你与这种想法的关系。当它再次出现时，你可以这样想：哦，又是大脑最喜欢的那个老套故事。我注意到我的大脑又在向我灌输那个故事了
that this relationship is wrong for me. Interesting. like here's my brain's favorite story to tell me right now and kind of change how seriously you're taking it. Consider how does it make sense that your brain is offering this to you? Oh, it makes total sense my brain wants to keep going back here because it's terrified of this relationship being wrong for me or it's terrified of me ever having to go through a breakup in five years time. Okay, so it makes sense that my brain keeps wants, keeps wanting to offer me these thoughts. So there's so much more work you can do and that there's different. kind of tools you can use for diffusing thoughts. There's things like you can kind of sing the
——这段关系不适合我。有意思。这就好像是：瞧，这是我大脑现在最喜欢讲给我听的故事。然后试着改变你对待它的严肃程度。想想看：为什么大脑会向你灌输这个想法其实是合乎情理的？哦，这太合理了，我的大脑总是想回到这里，因为它极度害怕这段关系真的不适合我，或者它极度害怕五年后我不得不经历一场分手。好吧，所以大脑总是忍不住想给我提供这些想法，这是完全说得通的。因此，你可以做更多的工作，并且可以运用不同的工具来消解这些想法。比如你可以把
intrusive thought to yourself. It kind of lightens the mood of it. There's things like kind of seeing the thought coming from this like separate voice from you. There's different things you can do, but that would be my advice to you is how can you make the occurrence of this thought less of a problem? Because what that's going to do is turn down the volume on it altogether. It's going to seem like less of a problem. And from there, your anxiety is going to come down a lot as well. This final question is for me. And I ask every single guest on the show this question, what is one piece of advice you'd have for anyone in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today? Well, the thing I was going to say was change our relationship to our
强力入侵的想法对自己唱出来。这会冲淡它的沉重感。或者把这种想法看作是来自你内心一个独立声音的产物。你可以做很多不同的事情，但这就是我给你的建议：如何让这种想法的出现不再是一个大问题？因为这会彻底调低它的音量，让它看起来不再那么严重。从那时起，你的焦虑也会随之大幅下降。最后一个问题是问我自己的。我向节目中的每一位嘉宾都问过这个问题：对于任何处于20多岁的人，你有一个什么建议是与我们今天讨论的内容完全无关的？好吧，我原本想说的其实是：改变我们与自己
thoughts. But I guess I can't say that. We've got nothing to do it. Honestly, yeah, I know. It's a bit of it. Honestly, yeah, I know. It's difficult. And yeah, honestly, then the, the piece of advice I'd give to anyone in their 20s, it's just to go easy on themselves. I know that sounds like such a basic thing to say, but I think sometimes it does kind of tie into what we're talking about, but we have so much pressure from things we see on social media, from expectations, maybe our parents have of us,
想法的关系。但我想我不能说这个了，毕竟要跟今天的话题无关。说实话，是的，我懂。这确实有点……说实话，是的，我明白，这很难。而且，说实话，我给20多岁的人的建议就是：对自己宽容一点。我知道这听起来像是一句非常基础的话，但我觉得有时候它确实跟我们刚才谈论的内容有些关联。我们在社交媒体上看到的各种事物、可能来自父母的期望，承受了如此之多的压力，
from what our, you know, friends are doing. And I think just remembering that, you know, life is supposed to be fun, that, you know, you can actually change so much of your experience of what you're going through in any situation by just lightening up and being a little bit more of a friend to yourself about it, you know, offering yourself that compassion, being your own biggest cheerleader, and remembering that, you know, that there's nothing that could happen that you couldn't be equipped to handle. And that is something I really focus on a lot with my own clients is looking at whatever that fear is that worst case scenario and considering, you know, how could I feel
还有朋友们都在做的事情。我认为只要记住：生活本该是充满乐趣的；其实你完全可以通过放松心情、对自己更友好一点，来彻底改变你在任何处境下的体验。你知道的，给予自己同情，做自己最大的啦啦队长。并且要记住，没有任何事情的发生是你无法应对的。这也是我在自己的学员身上非常注重的一点：审视那些恐惧和最坏的情况，并思考：如果它真的发生了，我该如何让自己
empowered to show up to handle that if it happened? You know, what would I want to think and feel if that happened? So yeah, I think kind of a mixed bag of advice there, of course, as I was going to say, your relationship to your thoughts and changing that is so, so important, but also working on having more of that lighthearted, compassionate, you know, kind of supportive relationship with yourself is such a game changer. And if you can master that in your 20s, your 30s, your 40s, it's going to all be great. If you can work on that relationship with you where you know, I'm going to have my own back no matter what happens. You know, it's going to be great. That's such a resounding, beautiful way to finish this episode. I want to thank you so much for coming on.
有力量去面对和处理？如果发生了那种情况，我想去想些什么、感受些什么？所以，是的，我觉得这是一个混合了各种建议的回答。当然，就像我刚才要说的那样，你与自己想法的关系以及去改变这种关系是非常非常重要的；但同时，努力与自己建立一种更加轻松、富有同情心且支持性的关系，也是一个彻底改变局面的关键。如果你能在20多岁时掌握这一点，那么在30多岁、40多岁时，一切都会变得非常好。如果你能处理好与自己的关系，无论发生什么，你都知道自己会永远支持自己。你知道的，这一定会很棒。这是一个如此响亮、美丽的方式来为这期节目画上句号。非常感谢你能来作客。
I'm going to leave all of your links below, but where can people find you? Yeah, amazing. So I'm on Instagram mainly. So you can find me at Rebecca or coaching. So that's Rebecca and then O-R-E coaching. You can also come find me on my podcast, which is Master Your Relationship, Mind Drama. And yeah, I'll send you all the links to the website and things like that. But yeah, it's Instagram on my podcast mainly where people can come find me
我会把你的所有链接都放在下方，但大家可以在哪里找到你呢？太棒了。我主要在Instagram上活动。所以大家可以在Instagram上搜索 Rebecca Or E coaching 找到我。那是 Rebecca，后面接着 O-R-E coaching。你也可以在我的播客上找到我，播客名字叫 Master Your Relationship, Mind Drama。是的，我会把网站以及其他相关的所有链接都发给你。不过，大家如果想找到我，主要还是通过我的Instagram和播客。
if they want to know more about thought work and managing their thoughts and managing their anxiety. I talk a lot about that on the podcast as well. I know your podcast is actually the perfect. If this is an episode that you really related to, go and check out Rebecca's podcast because there is so much advice there. But as always, if you enjoyed this episode as well, share it with a friend who might need to hear it. Leave a five-star review wherever you are listening.
如果他们想了解更多关于思维工作、如何管理自己的思维以及管理焦虑的内容，我在播客里也讨论了很多这方面的话题。我知道你的播客实际上是个完美的选择。如果你对这期节目深有共鸣，那就去听听丽贝卡的播客吧，因为那里有太多的实用建议了。不过，一如既往，如果你也喜欢这期节目，请把它分享给可能需要听到它的朋友。无论你在哪里收听，都请留下一个五星好评。
Make sure you're following along. And make sure you're following along on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. It's where I got the listener questions today. It's where I love to engage with you all. If you've made it this far into the episode, hello, lucky, lucky, lucky. I want you to leave a little magic crystal ball emoji in the comments because that's what we think our relationship OCD is and it's not. So it's also a great way to know. Be the loyal listeners.
确保关注我们。并且一定要在Instagram上关注 That Psychology Podcast。今天的听众问题就是从那里收集的，那也是我最喜欢与大家互动的地方。如果你一直听到了节目的最后，哈喽，那你真是太幸运、太幸运、太幸运了。我希望你在评论区留下一个水晶球的小表情符号，因为这就是我们看待自己关系强迫症的方式，但实际上它并不是。所以这也是一个很好的方法，能让我知道谁是我们的忠实听众。
Yeah, who's listened this far? And as always, we will be back next week. Until then, stay safe. Please be kind. In the theme of today's episode, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs.
是的，是谁听到了这里？和往常一样，我们下周还会回来。在此之前，请注意安全。请保持善意。顺应今天节目的主题，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快、很快就会再聊。2%。这就是选择走楼梯的
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
人群比例，而当时旁边明明也有自动扶梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 2%。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过同一个多产的诈骗犯时，
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们决定将命运掌握在自己手中。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《回顾过往》播客中。对1979年来说，那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起，
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? Listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过往》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难中学习》，由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人 Kear Games 主持。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都觉得其实并不安全的诚实对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男性穿着厚重的铠甲。它向世界传递的信号是：你可不好惹。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难中学习》。这是一档 iHeart 播客，保证真人录制。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。